Picture this.
You're in your car
and you're getting worried.
You were really, really relying
on that fuel station being open.
Now you're not sure
you're going to make it
to the next one you see on your map.
And this area is notorious
for unreliable stations.
You definitely don't have enough range
to make it to the one
that you know is usually working
or even the one that at least has
decent customer service
on their help line when it's down.
So you slow way down to conserve energy
and sigh when you see a giant hill
coming up on the freeway ahead of you.
The way people are driving,
there is no way you're going to make it
up this hill at a safe highway speed
without killing your energy efficiency.
It's hot out, but you turn off your AC
and remind yourself again
that charging your phone in the car outlet
doesn't actually use that much energy.
"Man," you think to yourself,
"I remember when this
was a problem for EVs.
But when I bought this car,
I just didn't think finding gasoline
was ever going to be
this much of a problem."
(Laughter and applause)
If we succeed at reaching
international climate goals,
the fossil fuel infrastructure systems
that support about 80 percent
of global energy consumption
will mostly, if not entirely,
retire over the next few decades.
The global dominance of fossil fuels
and the global emergency of climate change
means that this retirement
imperative exists everywhere,
whether infrastructure
is relatively old --
like in the US,
where I work on these issues
and where most of my examples come from --
or relatively newer,
as in many countries
with more recent industrialization.
What I'm talking about
is big infrastructure,
like power plants and refineries,
but it's also things
like gas stations and people's cars,
stoves and furnaces.
Fossil fuel infrastructure is a complex
network of high-hazard industries
that need to be able
to continue to operate safely
until the new system
is completely ready to take over,
including during emergencies
complicated by climate change.
Just letting these systems go away
would be deeply disruptive and hazardous.
We'd expect disproportionate harm
to overburdened
and underserved communities
who can't opt out
from skyrocketing prices,
abandoned remediation plans
and declining access to energy services.
This means ongoing fossil expenditures
and a reliance on highly trained workers
in industries that might not
outlast their careers,
with a simultaneous focus
on phasing out these same industries
as quickly as possible
to address climate change
and a host of other
environmental injustices.
This is why we need to plan.
And right now, there's basically
nowhere in the world
where these urgently needed plans
for phasing out the fossil system
while phasing in the clean
energy system exist.
When we talk about climate goals,
the question I like to ask is,
“If we actually believed
we were going to succeed,
what would we need
to be doing right now?”
The time between now and success
is where this gets real
and very difficult.
Sara Hastings-Simon and I
call this the mid-transition.
And even under a best-case scenario,
it will probably last for decades.
During the mid-transition,
the clean energy system
and the fossil energy system
are both too small to fulfill all
of the energy needs we have,
but big enough that they can't really
operate without constraining each other.
Also, the mid-transition overlaps
with the climate transition.
This means we'd expect the systems
we have now to become less functional
as they operate further and further
outside of design parameters.
And it also means we don't entirely know
what the new systems will need
to be able to handle.
Another issue here
is that we'd also expect
that the transitioning system
will just generally work less well
than either the stable starting point
or the stable end point.
As long as both systems
are operating at scale,
we can't optimize for either one's needs.
People are often willing to accept
some level of problem
in order to enable a shared future vision.
But trust in that vision
will be extraordinarily fragile
when it’s required for decades,
while climate impacts
are making everything scarier
and while we're visibly
dismantling infrastructure
that people remember as functional.
As we plan,
keeping a clear and focused
commitment on people first and foremost
and ensuring that these
are community-led projects
will be critical.
One of the nice things about existing
energy infrastructure is it exists.
So you can go to a power plant break room
and chat up people about how long
they expect to keep working
or which bits of the plant site
might need remediation.
This means planning
can be very, very specific
and guided by the expertise of people
that are in these places.
Who needs a job if the power plant closes?
Does everyone in town have safe
temperatures in their homes?
Which gas stations need to stay open
longer than they're profitable
to make sure that everybody
can get to work
while alternative
transportation systems mature?
How much extra funding
do you need for the library
if tax revenues start to decline?
Although good transition plans need
to be deeply community-embedded,
the scale and the impact
of the energy system
demands some level
of centralized coordination.
One strategy here is to set deadlines
for fossil asset retirements.
Ample notice, say a decade,
gives communities enough time
to create and implement plans,
and a legislated end date
gives people enough confidence
to commit to what can be
an intense process.
I showed that in the United States,
requiring all fossil fuel-fired
power generators to close by 2035,
which is President Biden's power sector
decarbonization target,
would actually allow
the large majority of them
to meet or exceed a typical lifespan,
potentially giving communities
some confidence
that these deadlines are manageable.
That may not be true in places
with much newer infrastructure
and so the conversation
about how to choose these deadlines
would look quite different.
But in general,
being honest with people
about what's coming,
with enough time and support
to do something about it
can be really transformative,
but it does require a commitment
to the end point
and to proactively ensuring
people have what they need
to thrive alongside transition.
That is what earns and maintains trust.
Not far off emissions targets
with vague implementation plans.
The alternative of unplanned transitions
is unacceptable, but common.
Notably, this is what
we would expect to see
if we just rely on clean energy
becoming cheap enough
to displace fossil energy systems.
What I've observed over the years
is that facilities might close suddenly
with a round of layoffs
and a bankruptcy notification
with very little notice
and no plan for what comes next.
Several years ago, I was working
on a survey in a coal mining community,
and the morning my survey
hit people's mailboxes,
about 500 coal miners
were suddenly laid off.
Just four US coal mining
companies used bankruptcy
to avoid about five
billion dollars in pensions
and environmental cleanup obligations
just between 2012 and 2017.
The coal industry in the United States
is actually pretty small,
now providing about 11 percent
of primary energy,
down from 18 percent a decade ago.
We're talking about successfully
retiring and replacing infrastructure
that supports 80 percent of energy use
globally and in the United States
all before I reach retirement age.
Planning the transition is an ethical
responsibility that takes time,
but also creates opportunities
to implement a just and sustainable future
that corrects the harms of the past.
Collaboration and a laser-like focus
on ensuring people have what we need
to succeed through this transition
will be critical,
particularly as the transition collides
with climate tragedies.
What would we do now
if we believed we'd succeed?
Anticipating the bumps
and planning for success
is the path to a just, decarbonized
and sustainable world.
Thank you.
(Applause)